hey all let's talk real quick here about
danos fancy miracle cure-all sliding
scale of movie badness first some
questions that I get asked a lot hey
what's the worst movie you've ever seen
is The Last Airbender the worst movie
you've ever seen is Jurassic world the
worst movie of the year what is possibly
worse than paul Blart 2 is Jack and Jill
the worst movie you've ever seen is
transformers the worst movie you've ever
seen God's not dead amazing spider-man
and in game aw it's the great and
powerful food fight This Means War
grown-up saddle [ __ ] john carter loraq
Atlas Shrugged sucker punch and of Steel
the worst movie that I've seen it's an
interesting question and I don't have a
definitive answer because I use danos
fancy miracle cure-all sliding scale of
movie badness the idea is simple when I
see a bad movie I weigh it against a
number of expectations like budget who
was involved and what kind of
distribution it's getting something like
The Last Airbender costs millions upon
millions of dollars brought in a lot of
good talent and was distributed to
thousands of screens worldwide so you
expect a baseline of competency that it
manages to fall so far below that mark
is part of what makes it special in
contrast murder on the sea train cost
probably 25 bucks including the train
tickets the cast and crew had to buy was
made by high-school students and was
distributed on VHS tapes after editing
the whole thing together tape to tape
straight from the hi-8 camcorder it's
way worse than the last airbender but
who cares I mean I doubt a copy of it
even exists anymore so I don't have a
worst film of all time because I've just
seen too much crap across too many
different levels of badness from
blockbusters that are offensive boring
and poorly scripted to zero budget
movies with an audible sound to movies
cut together from several different
incomplete films
and since everyone wants an answer cream
master 4 is probably it even after
weighing it's just it's unwatchable bad
don't see it watch something fun find a
copy of devil fish or modern vampires
that the the 4:20 movie is on YouTube
just don't watch Cree master there you
got an answer now go go go go and like
share and subscribe